olivier trilles et quel est votre talent
alors je suis hypnotiseur de spectacle
où l'eau est donc je peux congés les a
créés et des fous rires sous hypnose
borderais et ça se fait rapidement ou
pas ouais ben ça alors là c'est vrai que
gilles on l'a vu plusieurs fois dans des
émissions et et j'aimerais bien
justement le tester sa manière de
protester gilles mais elle et lui faire
créer un lien fort et soudé posé ses
malles avait oublié que dans celui des
ja oui alors j'ai testé aussi des gens
dans le public tout à l'heure par
exemple j'ai vu plusieurs personnes la
dame en rouge évoqué quelques quelques
personnes mais on met en fait je
préfèrerais le faire surtout le public
est allé voir gillain maintenant une
public vous allez le jil jilala les voir
gilles attention décor donne moi la main
c'est cette menace s'il te plaît allez
je regarde mes doigts plus tu regarde
mes doigts plus tes paupières deviennent
lourdes la tête pesant tu vas y prends
une bonne inspiration et tudor et tu te
sens merveilleusement bien
extrêmement bien dans cet état mais
merci je vais compter jusqu'à 3 gilles
méhu compétents et motivés les yeux
voici mais bien tu vas voir avant de
mourir un fou rire comme jamais et tu
sais pas ce que tu peux avoir
berne intro une tête drôle wine
extrêmement drôle 2 et 3 pour ouvrir les
yeux pendant manito olivier à travailler
alors il est temps d exil qui s'est
fracassé la tête par contre contre le le
passé très vite mais vous avez et j'ai
demandé dans quelle olivier de préparer
quelqu'un un public qui visiblement
s'est déjà endormi et des coiffeuses le
trompe olivier on est d'accord qu'elle
va se mettent à rigoler exactement est
ce que là pour l'instant c'est très
triste donc la danse à l'instant je vais
compter jusqu'à trois et au compte de 3
quand tu vas ouvrir les yeux et bien tu
vas avoir un fou rire un fou rire comme
jamais tuer parce qu au compte de 3
quand tu veux ouvrir les yeux et bien tu
vas voir tous les chroniqueurs ont tous
des têtes bizarre tous des têtes
rigolote et ça va te faire rire
extrêmement rire 1 2 et 3 ouvre les yeux
regarde moi toutes ces têtes et lorsque
tu vois ton voisin et on voit l'un ou ta
voisine tu rigoles de plus en plus
exactement comme ça et plus tu rigoles
et plus tu ressenti bien nette remontée
en toi de plus en plus et dans un
instant tu voir ce qui est drôle c'est
lorsque tu vas sentir ma main contrôle
contre ton épaule tu vas arrêter de ré
instantanément maintenant
[Applaudissements]